this is an exercise from khan academy it
tells us that the product 75 times 61 is
equal to 4575
use the previous fact to evaluate as a
decimal this right over here 7.5 times
0.061 pause this video and see if you
can have a go at it
all right now let's do this together so
the first thing that you might realize
is that 7.5 is the same thing as 75
divided by 10.
and 0.061
this is 61 thousandths
this right over here is the same thing
as 61
divided by 1000 and we're going to take
the product of these two things
another way we could write this
75 divided by 10 this is the same thing
as 75 over 10 and i'm going to take the
product of that and 61 thousands 61
divided by a thousand so that would be
61 over
a thousand
now when we look at it either of these
ways well actually i'll do both of them
at the same time you could change the
order of the multiplication and the
division here so you could start with 75
times 61
75 times 61 and then divide that by 10.
and then divide that by
a thousand
you could do it that way
or you can look right over here and say
all right if i'm taking this product my
numerator is going to be 75 times 61 75
times 61 and then my denominator is
going to be 10 times a thousand which is
essentially the same thing as dividing
by 10 and then dividing by a thousand
and of course that is going to be
ten thousand
now on the left hand side right over
here they told us what this is it's four
thousand five hundred and seventy five
so it's four thousand five hundred and
seventy five divided by 10 and then
divided by a thousand well if i divide
by 10 and then i divide by a thousand
that's equivalent to dividing by
10 000. this is
dividing
by
10
thousand and you can see that over here
we're dividing by ten thousand as well
right over here and the seventy-five
times sixty-one this is four thousand
five hundred and seventy-five now they
want us to evaluate it as a decimal
we've now expressed it as a fraction and
i still haven't fully evaluated this yet
so we really want to think about this as
four thousand five hundred seventy five
ten thousandths and you can see that
very explicitly here this four thousand
five hundred seventy-five ten 000
so how do we write that
well if i have
a decimal right over here that's the
tenths place
this is the hundredths thousandths
ten thousandths place so we have this
many ten thousands four thousand five
hundred
seventy-five
ten thousandths and we're done so this
is going to be zero point four five
seven five
now i know what some of you might be
thinking
hey
i learned a technique where if i'm
taking the product of two numbers i
could take the product of those two
numbers if i'm thinking the product of
two numbers that are decimals i could
remove the decimals from them
essentially take their product which
they actually gave us right over here
and then count how many digits to the
right of the decimal there were in our
original number so we have one
two
three
four digits to the right of the decimal
and so what i do is i then move i then
make sure that there's four digits to
the right of the decimal in the product
and so i would say okay one two three
four that looks good and i've got the
same answer a lot faster than we just
did it well the whole reason why i just
did it the way i did is to show you why
that works when we
take the product of the two numbers
without the decimals we're essentially
ignoring the fact that the original
product was dividing by 10 and dividing
by a thousand and that's because we had
one digit behind to the right of the
decimal here and we had three digits to
the right of the decimal there and so we
later after we take the product we have
to go and then actually take that
product and divide by 10 and divide by a
thousand or divide by 10 000 so that's
why you can then just say all right well
now we have we originally had four
digits to the right so we still have to
have four digits to the right of the
decimal point